hi my name is Karl Malone and I'm from
Canada so I first started studying
acting at Dawson College and I did that
for three years and after that I worked
for two years and much mostly in theater
and then I moved here to New York to
enroll at the Neighborhood Playhouse and
I graduated in 2015 and since then I've
been working here and this year at Quran
and I produced New York and it's doing
very well in the film festivals and
we're very proud of it hey all right I
also got a goal I have a date waiting
for me it just gave me a deal with the
old personal problems later huh my
personal problems you're the one who's
causing these personal problems Oh what
are you blaming me for getting yourself
locked out of your apartment
you're a delivery guy you got one job to
do if it'd have done a job like it's the
foreword you could throw food like
you're supposed to you make a living
because the people like me and you get
to enjoy hot food in bed because of
people like me yeah where is it where is
my hot food I didn't know are
you I just want to get my money and get
out of here the biggest problem for me
has been the business of acting I got
into acting because I was a passionate
about acting but then when you choose to
make it your career you have to buy into
the business of acting which can be
better headshots really going somewhere
you have to pay a lot of money for that
gain a real pain somebody for real then
agents managers networking with them
going to classes to meet casting
directors so many more and social media
is a big one and that class along with
my passion because I'm not really that
kind of person who is good at that I get
to be professional
so how I've been dealing with this
problem is I've been doing my own
projects because then that way I get my
own real I'm learning I have something
to talk about I am doing something
I'm not waiting by a phone I am active
as an actor you want to keep your
yourself tuned do you want to be always
acting more and more and
when you start off you think you're
gonna do that through actually like
auditioning and doing stuff that you'll
be paid for you know now it's the case
and so you can get in a rhythm of
becoming like I think someone said like
an audition mean actor like someone
who's good at auditions but when it
comes to like you know a full script
it's not like that it's actually foreign
to them cuz I've done it for a while
I've been fortunate I think were like a
silly monster I I consciously do is to
always try and act so I've done a lot of
plays for free which I am very grateful
for in the end because it's can be
fine-tuned
it's I'm working with people who worked
with worked longer in the business there
they I'm learning and knowing that I'm
being challenged with a new role and all
that so and that I think is just good
for my mind I think it keeps me happier
thank you so much for watching this
interview and my question would be to
you guys is if any of you who are actors
and producers what problems you come
into what problems to have you dealt
with the business and how have you
learned thank you